hello my name is Ben Brown I'm a
filmmaker and photographer and we are in
the Kruger National Park after meeting
my girlfriend Nicole in South Africa she
would often tell me about the challenges
facing the Rhinos after seeing it for
myself firsthand last year I began to
understand the reality of the situation
now we're both here to get the latest
updates on the war on poaching
[Music]
the war on rhino poaching is not a new
topic rhino have been wiped out in many
African countries with the largest
population now living in South Africa in
the Kruger National Park in 2014 over
1200 Rhino were poached in South Africa
the following year that number was
reduced to one thousand one hundred and
seventy five thanks to the efforts of
unite against poaching the demand for
rhino horn is at an all-time high
causing an average of ten poachers to
enter the park each day with the number
of incidences increasing it's incredible
to see the park gain more control of the
situation and reduce the number of post
Rhino my name is John Turner national
chairman of conservation services in the
South African national parks honorary
Rangers guarana crisis changed all our
lives about seven years ago Arana
perches basically for the horn they
leave the caucus behind that I'll take
any meat or anything like that and
constitute to public opinion the owners
seventy percent used for ornamental
purposes jewelry thirty percent of those
used for medicinal purposes and in the
East it's it's a great status symbol
branagh horn is now probably the most
expensive commodity on this planet
certainly overtaking gold things like
gold and platinum before the end users
paying up to $95,000 u.s. dollars a
kilogram originally when this crisis hit
us the first thing we had to do is
return all our field ranges and
re-equipment
we started with a couple of dogs also
some seven years ago or so and I think
the dock populations grown to about 50
now our success rate with catching
purchases has improved hugely with with
the use of dogs we have tracker dogs
which follows poor for us we would take
days to possibly check it and catch a
poacher whereas the dogs cutting that
down to hours now we then are looking
now and working towards also getting
sniffer dogs into our work at our gates
for sniffing for obviously animal parts
and also for bombs and ammunition the
piranhas in got in a good state in
Kruger in 2015 we've managed to show
read the reduction in the number of
animals lost and we confident that we
can take this on and we will eventually
win this one
okay we're off to go find Ben and SPE
they've hidden somewhere in the bush and
we're gonna take the tracker dogs with
us we're gonna test out their skills and
hopefully they're gonna snuff them out
let's see let's go so how long do you
train the dogs for they they go out into
the wild and track coaches every dog
just depends but it's average between
six to eight weeks okay and how long is
bad you been working in the field for
bears has been working in the field for
two years it is a big father a big fat
area so when you go there and it's
obviously always dangerous can it you
have to be aware of yeah perches are
heavily armed so it is it is
occupational hazard for the bucket but
the good dog can work them play from the
promise for about three to about seven
years I captain when the dogs have done
and they retired there are they get the
choice to go with the handler and you
can go in tension with your dog
[Music]
that's so amazing that is AB seeing it
all how's it feel being caught that's
pretty good it's hard to understand the
length of these volunteers go to protect
the Rhinos until you experience it
yourself
after having the opportunity to spend
some time with the volunteers staying in
their camp you understand the passion
and the love they have for the park the
Rhinos they protects and each of their
dogs from sniffing out arms and
ammunition to tracking poachers which
ultimately leads to increased arrests
it's clear to see these dogs are playing
a huge role in the war against poaching
limited funding means efficiency is key
and this increasingly expensive fight
against the poachers the war is by no
means over but there is more hope than
ever to save this beautiful species
you